la ciudad de ucraniana de jerson puede
estar liberada pero siguen apareciendo
denuncias de la barbarie rusa según kiev
aquí se descubrieron cuatro lugares de
tortura utilizados por Moscú la
situación es similar a unos kilómetros
de distancia en la ciudad liberada de
miko Life donde estos dos hombres
relatan los abusos que sufrieron
no teníamos baños nada teníamos que usar
botellas teníamos miedo de comer pero
nos daban de comer una vez al día no
comíamos porque nadie te llevaba al baño
por la noche
fueron arrestados el 22 de junio y
llevados a este centro de detención
donde dicen que los torturaron durante
siete días consecutivos para que
confesaran que trabajaban para los
servicios secretos de Ucrania
hubo algunos golpes la mayoría de las
veces los rusos me daban descargas
eléctricas la corriente me golpeaba los
pies las manos las orejas
y torturas con agua películas pensé que
era posible escupirla pero no es
realista
en repetidas ocasiones lo que llaman
crímenes de guerra por parte de Moscú
pero el kremlin aún no ha reaccionado a
estas acusaciones Aunque fueran
liberados del control ruso desde hace
más de una semana los habitantes de
gerson Siguen sin agua ni electricidad
es invierno pondrá en peligro la vida de
millones de personas en Ucrania Aunque
jerson sigue al borde de una crisis
humanitaria la ciudad continúa siendo
golpeada por los bombardeos rusos
mientras las autoridades instan los
habitantes a evacuar a zonas más